c'est qui le bras ces gens ne sont pas
des poux news ni des picots ils vivent
maintenant dans un pays libre et nous
avons pour mission de les aider à
apprécier le cours de la liberté
mais non si tu rentres tout bronzé tout
le monde te demandera où tu es parti et
là tu peux leur dire que tu es en irak
j'ai levé les champs en plus des fans de
4000 km
dans le brouillard de la guerre
chargez vos armes tout du flou fouillé
et arrêter les avec rigueur justice doit
être faite
même si ce sera dur
quand les règles
le sens pourquoi t'as fait ça ils
veulent m attaquer les hommes changent
et on a pris six tse [ __ ] de meurtrier
et on nous interdit d interroger alors
que c'est nous qui les avons pris on
fait la guerre à seissan culé si tu fais
pas ce soir d'un déserteur
torture et de crimes tout le temps des
images de ce qui s'est passé
apparaissent en permanence la loyauté
c'est tout ce qu'il reste mon gars qui
compte
duroux maltraite inutilement le temps de
cette occupation
ojala parc de 15
pour toujours